شهاده الدوره غير العاديه على المستوى
الوزاري المخصصه لمناقشه تطورات الاوضاع
في سوريا
تبادلا لوجهات النظر حول سبل تفعيل الدور
العربي القيادي في حل هذه الازمه الممتده
وبما يهدف بالاساس الى تسيير الوصول الى
السويسيه شامله لها تنهي معناه الشعب
السوري الشقيق وتحافظ وتحفظ وحده وسلامه
وعروبه بلاده اتزاخا مع
المرجعيات الدوليه للحل وقرار مجلس الامن
رقم 22 54
توافقت الدول المشاركه في الاجتماع لانه
لا حل عسكري لهذه الازمه ولا ضروره مواصله
وتكثيف الجهود العربيه الجماعيه للاسهام
في حلها
تم اعتماد قرار يتضمن دعم الدول الاعضاء
للخطوات المتخذه على صعيد تفعيل الدور
العربي في حل الازمه السوريه
وتاييد ما توصلت اليه اجتماعات الجده
وعمان من بلوره مقاربه تنفيذيه وفق منهجيه
خطوه مقابل خطوه وبما يهدف الى معالجه
جميع تباعات الازمه السياسيه والامنيه
والانسانيه
اتخذت الدول العربيه قرارا باستئناف
مشاركه وفد الجمهوريه العربيه السوريه في
اجتماعات مجلس جامعه الدول العربيه وجميع
المنظمات والاجهزه التابعه لها اعتبارا من
اليوم 7 مايو 2023
اكرر مجددا على ضروره وفاء كل من الحكومه
السوريه والقوه الوطنيه والمكونات السوريه
والمجتمع الدولي والدول المعنيه بالازمه
بالتزاماتها كل اتجاه الاخر ففي الوقت
الذي تطلع تطلع به الدول العربيه
بمسؤوليتها في دفع الحل السياسي للازمه في
سياق الجمود الدولي الحالي فان على
الحكومه السوريه وكل الاطراف سالفه الذكر
المسؤوليه الرئيسيه في الوصول لهذا الحل
وتنفيذ الالتزامات ذات الصله لكي تعود
سوريا الى السوريين موحده ومستقره ومستقله
كما نسعى جميعا
ان الموقف المصري منذ بدء الفتره
الانتقاليه في السودان ارتكز على دعم
السودان وعلى كافه المستويات
والمطالبه بوقف الفوري لاطلاق النار
والاشتباكات المسلحه حرصا على حياه
المدنيين وحفاظا على مقدرات الدوله
السودانيه شقيقه ودعم الجهود العربيه
لحلحله الازمه من انطلاقا من الارتباط
الامن القومي للبلدين كل منهما بالاخر
وحفت مصر الاشقاء في السودان على الحوار
والعمل معا كشركاء خصماء هناك اهميه
وضروره بالغه للتحرك العربي السريع
والمؤثر حاليا ومن هنا جاء قرار انشاء
لجنه اتصال من بين اعضاء الجامعه العربيه
تهدف لوقف اطلاق النار والسماح بالممرات
الانسانيه لاحتياجات المدنيين والحفاظ على
مؤسسات الدوله وعدم تعريضها للخطر
الانهيار الذي يهددها حاليا
وكعادتها في
موقفها الثابت من الترحيب باشقائها
السودانيين استقبلت مصر منذ اندلاع الازمه
حتى الان عدد وفير من مواطنين السودانيين
كما ساهمت في اجلاء نحو 4000 من الرعايه
الاجانب في السودان خلال نفس الفتره هناك
حتميه لعوده للحوار السياسي في السودان في
هذه اللحظه التاريخيه الفارقه والتي يتعرض
فيها الوطن الوطن لاخطار وجوديه ووضع
اعتبارات مصلحه السودان وامنه فوق اي
اعتبارات ضيقه اخرى
ناحيه اخرى ان عقدت اليوم دوره غير عاديه
على المستوى الوزاري لمناقشه تطورات
الاوضاع في فلسطين تم خلالها تناول
التحديات التي تواجه القضيه الفلسطينيه
وسبل مواجهه الاعتداءات الاسرائيليه على
حقوق الشعب الفلسطيني وكيفيه العمل على
احياء العمليه السياسيه واطلاق عمليه
تفوضيه تهدف لتحقيق السلام العادل والشامل
وانشاء الدوله الفلسطينيه على حدود الرابع
من يونيو
وعاصمتها القصه الشرقيه شكرا على حسن
الاستماع ويتفضل معالي الامير العام
شكرا شكرا سياده الرئيس انا الحقيقه ليس
لدي
نقاط استطيع ان اطرحها اتوقع الكثير من
الاسئله ولما كنت اتوقع هذه الاسئله فهمني
ان انا اسبقها
ببعض النقاط لعلها تفتح الطريق للاسئله
القرارين
تم تبنيهم النهارده
قرار على السودان
واحد العناصر الاركان الرئيسيه لهذا
القرار هو تشكيل لجنه متابعه وتواصل
واتصال من
مصر مملكه العربيه السعوديه والامين العام
[موسيقى]
للتواصل مع اطراف النزاع للتواصل مع
المجتمع الدولي لتحقيق الهدف زي ما هو
باين في القرار الخاص بالسودانه فيما
يتعلق
بالقرار الخاص بسوريا
بالاضافه الى
الدعوه الى عوده سوريا الى شغل مقعدها في
الجامعه العربيه هو ايضا قرار بينشئ لجنه
متابعه من
مصر
والسعوديه
والاردن والعراق والامين العام وهو ايضا
وهي لجنه ايضا مهمتها المتابعه
تسويه القضيه السوريه
عوده سوريا الى شغل المقعد
هي بدايه حركه وليست نهايه مطاف بمعنى انه
مسار التسويه للازمه السوريه هتاخذ مرحله
من الاجراءات والتدرج فيها ومهمه هذه
اللجنه هي متابعه هذه
الاجراءات ايضا هي ليس
بقرار
لاقامه علاقات طبيعيه بين الدول العربيه
وسوريا هذا قرار سيادي لكل دوله على حده
نحن نتحدث في هذا القرار عن
شغل المقعد وتشكيل اللجنه للتواصل مع
الحكم في سوريا والحكومه السوريه
فعوده سوريا هي بدايه للطريق وليس نهايه
للمسار
هذا لا يفترض ان الازمه السوريه حلت بل
على العكس هو يدخل الجانب العربي لاول مره
منذ سنوات في تواصل مع الحكومه السوريه
للبحث في كافه عناصر المشكله
الضاغطه على سوريا وهناك عناصر كثيره جدا
تم مناقشتها سواء في
عمان او في اجتماع
جده
وبالقرار
بيتناول
الاقتراب من المشكله السوريه بشكل تدريجي
وهو بالتالي قرار واقعي للغايه لانه يعلم
انه لا يمكن تسويه هذه القضيه في يوم او
في شهر فهي هتاخد وقتها
هذا يعني انه الحكومه السوريه سوف تتواجد
في كافه مدوئات
الجامعه العربيه ومنظمتها الاقليميه
واجتماعاتها الوزاريه ما بين اجتماعات
المندوبين الى
القمه وسوف نقوم باخطار
الجانب السوري ربما مسائل يوم ربما صباح
باكر
رسميا بهذا القرار وعناصره كلها شكرا
جزيلا سياده الرئيس
الامانه العامه ولرئاسه الجلسه فيما يتعلق
بهذا القرار البند الثلاثه والبند الخمسه
المتعلق بالعوده في ثلاثه بنتحدث عن مسار
هو مجرد خطوه على طريق كما اشرت حضرتك وهو
كان نتيجه لجهود سابقه تم البناء عليها في
قرار 2011 كان هناك اشاره الى ان تجميد
عضويه سوريا في الجامعه العربيه مرتبط
بعدم تعاطيها مع ما سمي انذاك بالمبادره
الحل العربي هل حصلتم سواء عبر اللقاءات
التمهيديه في جده او في عمان على التزام
من الطرف السوري بان يتعاطى ايجابيا مع
هذا الامر لانه المعترضين على هذا القرار
كانوا يرون ان على جانب السوره ان يقدم
ايضا خطوات في هذا الاتجاه هل لدى الامانه
العامه او رئاسه الدوره اتصال بالجانب
السوري يعني يعطي من خلالها هذا الجانب
السوري التزاما بالمضي قدما في حل المشكله
الاساسي للازمه السوريه ومن ثم يصبح هذا
القرار يعني ذي جدوى ومن الممكن البناء
عليه
انه واضح انه القرار اشار بشكل واضح الى
المخرجات الخاصه بالاجتماع الذي عقد في
الجده ومتلاهم الاجتماع عقد في عمان
والبيان الذي صدر وانضم اليه وزير خارجيه
سوريا وهذا البيان متضمن كافه الابعاد
الخاصه بالازمه السوريه
وضروره التفاعل الايجابي مع كل المكونات
سواء كانت سياسيه او انسانيه
وقضايا اخرى
ذاتها تاثير على المحيط الاقليمي وقضيه
تواجد القوات الاجنبيه
وضروره تفاعل سواء الحكومه او كافه
المكونات السياسيه السوريه من اجل التوصل
الى الحلول التي
يرتديها الشعب السوري وتؤدي الى استعاده
سوريا لكامل سيادتها واستقراره امنها
ووفقا للمرجعات الدوليه
والمقررتها واعلى راسها القرار 22 54
فما تم ابداءه من قبل الحكومه السوريه
خلال اللقاءات الثنائيه التي عقدت قبل
الاجتماعين ثم تداول الذي تم خلال
الاجتماعات يؤكد وكما تحدثت في الكلمه في
الجلسه بان هناك مسؤوليه تقع على الجميع
وانما هو اسكاء
اذا تبعنا واياكم المؤتمر الصحفي من
القاهره
لامين عام الجامعه العربيه احمد ابو الغيط
وسامح شكري وزير الخارجيه المصري لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات